[موسيقى]
في دورية مع
ناقلات جند مدرعة تابعة لقوات حفظ السلام التابعة للأمم المتحدة
تجوب مدن وقرى
جنوب لبنان، هذا هو الشكل الذي
تبدو عليه الدورية اليومية لقوات
حفظ السلام التابعة للأمم المتحدة، وكما ترون فإنهم
يأخذون الأمن على محمل الجد في
المجتمعات القريبة من الحدود مع
إسرائيل المجاورة  تبدو وكأنها
مهجورة لأن هذه
المنطقة الحدودية المتوترة كانت مسرحًا
لنزاع مميت عبر الحدود بين
الجيش الإسرائيلي وميليشيا الحسبة اللبنانية، وهي
السياج الأمني ​​الإسرائيلي الذي يقع على بعد بضع مئات من الياردات فقط،
كما أن
مركز حفظ السلام التابع للأمم المتحدة هذا قريب جدًا  نظرًا لأننا نستطيع
الوصول بأمان إلى الحدود اللبنانية مع
إسرائيل والتي كانت بمثابة خط أمامي الآن
في الصراع المستمر منذ أكثر من
شهرين من هذا الموقع، يمكننا
بسهولة رؤية قرية أفيفيم الإسرائيلية مهجورة
أيضًا على ما يبدو، فهي أكثر هدوءًا
اليوم وقبل ذلك  هذا الصباح
سمعنا بضعة انفجارات لملازمنا الشرقي
إي إس أو كونيل يقود
فصيلة مكونة من حوالي 30 جنديًا أيرلنديًا ومالتيًا
في هذه المخفر الصغير، هل حدث أي
من هذه الانفجارات، أي من هذه
الذخائر تقترب من هذا الموقع أم نعم، لقد كان
لدينا  "كان لدينا بعض الأراضي على بعد 300
متر من الموقع هنا. وقد تم
نشر قوة حفظ السلام الموحدة في جنوب لبنان منذ عام 1978
وتتكون حاليًا من أكثر من
10000 جندي، وتتمثل مهمتها الأساسية في
مراقبة حدود هذه الخيمة ومساعدة
القوات المسلحة اللبنانية في تولي المسؤولية".  الأمن
هنا مجرد وجودنا هنا يجعل من
الصعب جدًا على الجهات الفاعلة على كلا
الجانبين أن تفعل أه هل نقول
أشياء بغيضة في هذه المنطقة جنوب لبنان هو
معقل
ميليشيا الحسبة القوية المدعومة من إيران والتي
يمتزج مقاتلوها في
الريف يقول حزب الله ذلك
يهاجم إسرائيل لإظهار الدعم
للفلسطينيين في غزة،
والجيش الإسرائيلي يسارع إلى الانتقام، لقد
رأينا صواريخ موجهة متقدمة مضادة للدبابات، وشاهدنا
غارات جوية،
وشاهدنا ضربات مدفعية، وشاهدنا
إطلاق نار من أسلحة صغيرة على الرغم من هذه الأسلحة.
قوات حفظ السلام لديها تفويض فقط
بإطلاق النار دفاعًا عن النفس ومهمتها
خطيرة خلال حرب استمرت شهرًا
مع الحسبة في عام 2006، أسفرت الضربات الإسرائيلية عن
مقتل خمسة من قوات حفظ السلام التابعة للأمم المتحدة وإصابة
عدد أكبر، وفي العام الماضي هاجم مسلح لبناني
مركبة تابعة للأمم المتحدة مما أسفر عن مقتل جندي أيرلندي.
جندي حفظ السلام وإصابة ثلاثة
آخرين بجراحه نفى اتهامات قضاة لبنانيين
بأن المشتبه به الرئيسي كان
عضوًا في حزب الله عند غروب الشمس، تردد صدى محركات
الطائرات الإسرائيلية بدون طيار فوق التلال، هناك
رجال ونساء وأطفال عاديون يعيشون
هنا في جنوب لبنان، بل وفي الواقع
عبر الحدود  في إسرائيل، أملي
هو أن ينحسر الصراع، لكن هل
أشعر بالقلق من أنه سيتصاعد بشكل
مطلق؟ قوات حفظ السلام تخشى
عدم قدرتها على منع هذا الصراع من التصاعد
إلى حرب أكبر بكثير. إيفان واتسون سي إن إن
على الحدود اللبنانية مع
إسرائيل